you've been in so many TV shows and
films we saw a little bit about Game of
Thrones in shagger a great character
what did you enjoy about playing him oh
he was great shagger
it was great to play somebody who was so
different from me you know and looks so
different and to have that huge makeup
job done and in a play a wild man in the
forest and get to do scenes with Charles
dance and Peter Dinklage and it was
great fun shooting in Belfast very cold
but worth it was it like wearing that
makeups even you've got a big full
costume as well with all the horns and a
helmet and all the gear haven't you as
well as the makeup yeah it was a huge
big makeup job it's a big big beard and
big big wagon but it was very cold so I
was quite glad to be playing playing a
man who wore lots of the thick costumes
and lots of hair kept me warm there were
some people there who were wearing a lot
less and they suffered now you mentioned
Charles dance and also Peter Dinklage
sir what was it like working with those
guys well both very nice you know but
lovely people and easy to work with and
Charles dance work we were doing scenes
in his tent that those scenes in his
tent and it was a night shooting he was
very very cold and he it was great fun
you know just went it was just one of
the other actors you know and as was
Peter and that big scene I did with
Peter in the forest with the ring and
nice day you know
good good yeah absolutely you remember
that call it line of how would you like
to die Tyrion that's like one of the
favorite lines yeah yeah and here's his
response to that as well yeah now what
kind of qualities do you think you need
to survive in a world like Game of
Thrones because we see so many actors
and characters fall by the way so don't
worry shagger still low Shagga still
alive so bring him back yeah yeah I
guess there's so many characters you
know that um there's just thousands of
characters so you just don't just kind
of do your bit and and see what happens
and go with the flow you know and and
and that's fine you know I mean don't be
don't get too stressed about it what do
you think the chances are we'll see
sugar back in the game of Thrones
universe I think I think it'd be great
at shagger back and that unfortunately I
don't make those decisions
you